game number six for how fourth start
this season he doesn't have a win he's
owen two but he's got a very good earned
run average at 250. this is his first
career appearance against the blue jays
he's a former first round draft pick
back in 2017
but before that he was a draft pick of
the toronto blue jays a 12th round draft
pick in 2014
they could not come to a deal so he went
to college improved his lot signed as a
former first round draft pick and here
he is facing the blue jays fastball
slider splitter
houck throws a breaking ball swung on
and missed
for strike three boy does he work fast
springer gone on four pitches to open
the game another 3-2 pitch
strike three he started that breaking
ball inside and broke it over the inside
corner for a strikeout
that is called the front door
when you start that slider at the hitter
you freeze him
and pollicky catches it on the inside
corner good start for the young rookie
tanner houck tanner pitching like he has
a dinner reservation downtown at nine
o'clock he's also making really good
hitters look awful right now really bad
i think the pace helps too breaking ball
strike three beautiful slider on the
outside corner of the knees houck
strikes out the side
in the first inning
steven matt's last pitched on friday
night in new york against his former
team and pitched into the sixth inning
gave a couple of runs in the first
inning then settled down just three
measly singles
then into the sixth inning he uh ended
up losing that ball game because the
blue chase got shut out three to nothing
kk in with 14 home runs
tags that one to center springer is
backing up back it up it's over his head
on the track out there in the triangle
hernandez romping into second bases
stand up double and a nice start for the
sox tonight kiki loves that first pitch
and he loves that first pitch especially
if it's a fastball from the middle and
this ball was quickly over the head of
springer in center field there's that
fastball middle
and he takes it right back up the middle
for the line drive double insects only
five hits in the opener raphael devers
had two of those as single and a double
one two and there's a base sitting
center
kick into third
he's coming in here's the throw that'll
be cut the run scores play at second he
is out
debra's cut down trying to get to second
base red sox do get on the board though
as he will pick up his 82nd rbi yeah
debra's taking a shot here to try to get
second on that's throw to springer it
was in the in the dirt actually just a
little short hop that guriel does a nice
job kind of backhanding really looks
more like a middle infielder on this
place nice job getting it to simeon at
second base and they get just in time
one two pitch pokes that one the other
way for a base head that's a beautiful
thing so matz has allowed hits the first
three red sox tonight he hit a solid
line drive played on a couple of hops by
randall grichik so zander returns to
action with a base hit that's good to
see
three two high twisting fly ball that's
well struck back there's springer on the
track
to make the catch
sucks get some good cuts early here
against matt's and two down swing and a
fly ball center field pretty well hit
even though renfro had to reach for it
it's springer back on the warning track
again to make the catch so
a lot of loud noise made by the red sox
bats in that first inning but they get
just the one run the pitch for matt well
it's a good decision line driving a base
hit through the right side to the
infield and on into right verdugo
hitting just 203 for the year against
left-handed pitchers before that at bat
and now has a hit in each game of this
double header he was one for three this
afternoon
this is a changeup he's gonna wait back
at the barrel of the bat of the ball
and take it into right field for the
base hit
pounding ball toward the hole and threw
for a base hit
up to second verdugo and here come the
red sox again first and second nobody
out so they'll send up duran for the
first time in this one get an rbi
opportunity here second and third with
one gone
high fly ball right field deep backing
up grichik under to make the play
tagging up here comes verdugo
and plawecki will also advance down to
third
long fly the sacrifice for duran
and the red sox are leading at two to
nothing another one-two pitch to george
springer here it is and he swings and
misses at a slider a foot outside strike
number six they leave a runner at second
that retires the side
there's a fly ball deep to center field
and this one is going to be at the base
of the wall it's a base hit for guerrero
and he'll end up at second
and friday guerrero has the first hit
for the blue jays he says vamos let's go
boys come out
so he gets a lead off double right here
in the fourth he's such a good hitter
understands how to how to take things
and and lay off of those tough pitches
now they can get a run back on a ground
ball with the infield back
hits it hard right back up the middle
and that'll score guerrero so that pass
balls cashed in immediately as bobachet
picks up another rbi
that's 68 ribbies for bow and it's a
one-run game second strikeout for matt's
and here's duran who hit a ball almost
to the warning track out by the red sox
bullpen it went for a sacrifice fly
durant hit 15 home runs at worcester
tags that one into the gap that's under
the grass that's going to keep on
rolling all the way up against the wall
don't over run them jared yeah here
comes blowicky he is in the scar here
comes the kid he's trying to score plant
to play he's safe
wow
holy cow
he was an absolute blur
and an inside the parker oh is that ever
fun to watch when this kid pushes it
into second gear
he is flying and he had no intention of
stopping a little bobble right there by
springer they just continue to wave him
home beautiful slide head first
put the shoulder right into the catcher
oh that one is hit hard rising to the
wall way up there and that's high off
the monster here comes [ __ ] in the throw
into second kk back to third and another
extra base hit raphael debras is out
grabbing the
hamstring
he is done for the night we'll see what
that means for the remainder of this
series and moving forward comes the 1-1
swing broken back grounded a second
here's the flip to the shortstop out
onto first and somehow they double him
up boy didn't seem possible but it was
sitting close to the bag
and snead does a good job in his major
league debut five innings complete here
red sox four
jays
one for one game
in the seventh which does feel like the
ninth
he's seven in the games that one's
tagged nice play by dalton
out there
and the red sox pull out the win
a scalded shot
dulbeck with a nifty pick to start the
game ending double play and a red sox
split they take the nightcap 4-1